. Musik Es ist wirklich, Flöten-UFO was sonst, ihr habt's
ja auch selber angemacht, ihr habt bestimmt auch nichts anderes erwartet als unsere stimmen oder
vielleicht doch aber dann habt ihr euch verdrückt auf den falschen podcast gedrückt das kann schon
mal passieren das nehmen wir euch nicht übel aber dann seid ihr bestimmt etwas sauer. meiner Seite darf ich euch herzlich vorstellen, Florentin Will oder wie ich ihn immer nenne, Florentin Will. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Ich habe mir letztens nachgedacht, du hättest glaube ich den perfekten Namen, um in die Pornoindustrie einzusteigen. Einfach, wie heißt eigentlich unser Regisseur? Well, his name is Steven Titz. Tizzi, ja. Ein perfekter Name. Du aber auch. Also Will, Will. Ja, ja. Es ist auch ein guter Name, es ist auch ein guter Name für die Pornoindustrie. Einigen wir uns darauf, dass wir überall anders besser aufgehoben werden als hier im Podcast. Mit genug Fantasie ist, glaube ich, jeder Name ein guter Name für die Pornoindustrie. Es gibt doch dieses Spiel, was war dein erstes Haustier, der Name war dein erstes Haustiers und der Mädchenname deiner Mutter, das ist dein Pornotitel. Wie würdest du das heißen? Warte mal, da hatte ich letztes Mal eine Gag-Idee. So, was ist … warte mal ganz kurz. Das könnte auch gut auf deinem T-Shirt stehen. T-Shirt, wo draufstehen … Ich hätte da mal eine Gag-Idee. Letztes Mal eine Idee, ja, genau. Ne, sag mal bitte, wie würdest du heißen? Dein erstes Haustier. Wie heißt dein erstes Haustier? Miechen. Miechen und der Mädchennamen deiner Mutter? Kraus. Ja. Das wäre ja so aus den Dreissigerjahren irgendwie wäre Tweety Richter. Das ist immer gut. Tweety Richter, the judge is in the house. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber ich hatte immer sowas wie von wegen, ja, dein Pornoname ist der Beruf deines Vaters und die Straße, in der du aufgewachsen bist. Okay, mein Pornoname ist Professor Eich. Ja, sehr guter Gag. Ja, vielen Dank. Mit diesem heißen Gag starten wir direkt in die nächste Folge. Wir haben hier natürlich ein fantastisches Thema für euch ausgegramm, natürlich. Und zwar geht es heute um … Ihr kennt uns ja nicht anders. Heute geht es um Zeit. Was ist Zeit? Wohin führt Zeit? Wir sagen, was war früher besser? War früher wirklich alles besser oder ist es wieder so typisches Dahergelabere, wie sieht die Zukunft aus, wie sieht meine Zukunft aus, wie war unsere Vergangenheit, wir blicken auf den Podcast zurück, wir blicken auf den Podcast nach vorne, weil wir uns immer im Kreis drehen thematisch, aber das ist heute nicht schlimm, es geht um Zeit. Zeit ist ja nur eine Aneinanderreihung von Reihen letztendlich. Es ist eigentlich nur, Dinge passieren und man weiss nicht genau, wie man das beschreiben soll, außer mit Zeit und der Veränderung. Das Thema trägt genau fünf Sekunden. Genau, zwölf Sekunden und das war es dann schon. Naja, wie war es in der Woche, Stefan? War sehr gut. Ne, ganz ehrlich, ich habe mir heute gedacht, Zeit. Sind Zeitreisen möglich? Ich habe mir so ein paar Stichpunkte gemacht, die ich ansprechen wollte. Zeitreisen, die klapperst du einfach. Ich habe schon drei von fünf. Hatten wir uns nicht mehr über Zeitreisen unterhalten, von wegen, dass es schwer ist, auch das Örtlich festzulegen?
Ich finde es langsam aus Archivgründen schwierig, dass wir in Folgen, in denen es nicht um bestimmte Themen geht, trotzdem schon Themen ansprechen, die wir dann in späteren Folgen möglicherweise ansprechen. Das stimmt. Wir haben schon sehr viel, eigentlich haben wir schon alles über Zeit gesagt. Heute werden wir auch wieder Themen ansprechen, vielleicht wir über Bäume reden oder Pfandflaschen. Und das wird uns dann vorweggreifen, wenn wir wirklich mal eine Folge über Pfandflaschen machen. Dann haben wir echt ein Problem. Wir müssen, glaube ich, einfach mal, entweder wir benennen die Folgen dann letztendlich so, wie sie dann waren. Nein, ich glaube, wir machen das ganz anders. Ich würde sagen, wir sagen heute einfach mal Danke. Man muss auch in einem gewissen Rahmen auch einfach mal Danke sagen. sagen danke an unsere zuhörer die uns so toll unterstützt haben bis jetzt auf dem weg
den so viele tolle input gegeben haben so viele themenvorschläge so viele tolle Gags die wir in
der sendung umsetzen konnten einfach mal vielen dank auch an itunes an das internet an generell
elektronische Datenverarbeitung im generellen dass das alles überhaupt möglich geworden ist. Vielen Dank dafür für alle unsere Zuhörer. So, los geht's.
Du spielst Zwölftonmusik, sehr gut.
Ich war mal bei so einem, ich war mal bei so einem, ich weiß nicht, ob du jemals Musikunterricht genommen hast, aber da gibt es dann immer so tolle Abende, wo dann alle vorspielen müssen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist immer die Hölle eigentlich. Und da war ich dann auch mal mit einem Freund dabei, der Klavier gespielt.
Davor waren natürlich auch ein paar jüngere Kinder als er und da waren auch ein paar Geigenspielerinnen dabei, so kleine Mädchen, die Geige gespielt haben. Und dann war es so, dass dann die Lehrerin ankam und hat sich ans Klavier gesetzt und hat die Kleine begleitet und hat so ganz schön begleitet und hat die Kleine angefangen zu krächen. Und ich habe mir echt gedacht, es wäre echt viel geiler, wenn man nur das Klavier hören könnte, nur die Begleitung, kann nicht einfach das kleine Mädchen aufhören zu spielen. Aber die funktioniert einfach so, wenn die Hauptperformance das negativste des Abends ist. Diese Vorspielabende, die waren so klasse, da waren so viele kleine Facetten, die Spaß gemacht haben. Zum Beispiel allein der Ablaufplan. Am Anfang waren immer bei uns die, wir hatten teilweise nur Vorspielabende von Leuten, die auch Gitarrenunterricht hatten, wie ich damals. Und dann waren die ganz neu angefangen haben, immer ganz am Anfang. Und es wurde halt immer besser Richtung, wie später der Abend war war und dann am Anfang haben halt immer Leute gespielt, die so gerade mal überhaupt, wenn es so gerade das Instrument gerade mal in der Hand halten konnten. Und es war so witzig, weil die es einfach immer verschissen haben, hat sich immer, wenn man selber da noch sass und noch gleich noch dran war, man war saunervös, alle Eltern gafften. Und es wurde ja jedes Jahr schlimmer, weil man wurde ja jedes Jahr älter und wurde weiter ans Ende gerückt und musste jedes Jahr noch länger warten.
Ich habe mich über jeden Verspieler von anderen gefreut, weil man dachte, ha, Idiot, da muss man nochmal anfangen wohl. Was ich tatsächlich mal das Problem hatte, und zwar Musikstücke sind ja oft so aufgebaut, dass es irgendeinen gewissen Teil gibt, dann wird der wiederholt und dann geht es anders weiter und dann wird übergeleitet ins Ende. So, und ich hatte mal das Problem, dass ich den ersten A-Teil gespielt habe, wiederholt habe, aber dann irgendwie instinktiv wieder in die Wiederholung reingegangen bin. Und dann habe ich mich immer im Kreis gedreht und ich dachte, was ist denn los? Aber das stimmt für sich 80 Minuten lang, die ersten Eltern wackeln schon unruhig auf jeden Sitzen, ein Vater rennt schon raus. Und du spielst dann immer wieder im Kreis und du wirst langsam nervös, weil du spielst, was deine Finger dir sagen und was du kannst, aber du kommst nicht zum Ende und denkst, das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Das ist aber auch normal, weil ich konnte zum Beispiel nie nach Noten spielen. Also ich konnte die Noten irgendwann lesen, habe mir dann das Stück drauf geschafft und dann habe ich auswendig gelernt das Stück und habe die Noten nie wieder angerührt.
So und dann hat man das Instinktiv, spielt man dann halt nach Gefühl und wenn man das halt im Kopf hat, dass es jetzt eine Wiederholung kommt und man kommt gerade nicht mehr drauf, wie es weitergeht, dann ist es halt so, da muss man halt mal 80 Minuten durchhalten. Alles schönste auch dann der Blick zum Musiklehrer, der hilfesuchende Blick, der dann irgendwie ganz nervös mit Schweiß auf der Stirn guckt, so, ich kann dir nicht helfen, so, leite über ins Ende und dann irgendwie macht man einfach mitten im Stück bei irgendeinem Akkord einfach Brrring und hört einfach mitten im Stück auf. Dankeschön, danke, weil man einfach nicht mehr rauskommt. Das ist ein tolles Kreis. Und ich finde es immer so geil, wie die eigenen Eltern dann immer am lautesten klatschen von allen und man genau immer die Elternteile sieht. Man kennt die ganzen Leute gar nicht mehr, man weiß aber genau am Ende, wer zu wem gehörte, weil die Eltern natürlich immer am stolzesten klatschen, am lautesten klatschen und immer auch so hilfesuchend umgucken. Ja, das ist mein Sohn, das ist mein Sohn.
Das hat ein Freund von mir, der hat auch Gitarre gespielt, der hat dann auch ein Stück vorgespielt.
Und da war im Stück irgendwie, war dann auch irgendwie erst ein Teil, dann der andere Teil.
Und beim zweiten Teil stand dann A Tempo, also schneller.
Und das hat der Musiklehrer, glaube ich, in der letzten Musikstunde noch so gesagt, so ja, den Teil dann einfach ein bisschen schneller spielen.
Und er hat das dann aber ein bisschen missinterpretiert und hat dann bei der Aufführung den ersten Teil normal gespielt und den zweiten dann wie dreimal so schnell.
Viggen, der schnell. Und der Musiklehrer auch komplett nervös, komplett aufgesprungen, was ist denn jetzt hier los? Das stelle ich mir auch großartig vor. Der arme Musiklehrer, der tut mir immer am meisten leid, der immer nur seine Schäfchen durch den Arm bringen will, aber die sich einfach immer selber ein Bein stellen und einfach immer selber in Probleme einverstricken. Und er kann ihnen nicht helfen.
Aber ich finde das auch ein bisschen unfair, weil je nachdem, was man für ein Instrument hat, kann man da halt relativ schnell versagen oder relativ schnell auch das Publikum auf seine Seite holen.
Zum Beispiel war bei uns immer am Ende, wenn Musikabende waren, wo halt viele Leute von anderen Instrumenten gespielt haben, dann wurde ganz ans Ende immer die Keyboarder gesetzt.
Die konnten zwar auch nicht so viel, aber die haben halt so ganz peppige Marimba Nummer fünf Begleitungen gehabt, so auf den Casio Keyboards. Den Bossa Nova Beat nebenbei. Genau, der Bossa Nova haben sie einen rausgeholt am Ende noch, wo dann die Eltern immer instinktiv aufgesprungen sind und auf eins und drei mitgeklatscht haben. Und das ist natürlich immer sehr einfach. Und du kannst halt, also der Beat ist halt cool und der macht halt die ganze Arbeit für dich. Und die konnten im Endeffekt halt alle meine Entchen-like nur so ein paar Töne spielen, ein paar Tonleiter runterklimpern. Aber es waren halt die Sympathieträger des Abends, weil der Beat so treibend war. Genau. Es ist genau wie das kleine Mädchen, das Geige spielt, aber alle eigentlich nur sagen, oh, das ist ja eine schöne Begleitung von der Musiklehrerin. Alle klatschen, alle, aber eigentlich für die Musiklehrerin. Aber das Mädchen ist total happy. Aber ich finde es ja schön, ich bin in so einer Kleinstadt aufgewachsen und da ist ja immer so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl, so ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl und die verschiedenen Leute bringen ihren Beitrag zur Gemeinschaft und da war dann irgendwie so ein Strassenfest oder irgendwie sowas und da sollte dann auch eben die Gitarrenmusikgruppe sollte da so ein Stück spielen für die Leute und so ein kleines Konzert machen. Das Problem war nur, an dem Tag war es sehr windig und sehr laut tatsächlich auch und man hat uns kaum gehört. Man spielt dann so gegen den Wind an und dann hat mein Musikleiter den genialen Satz, den ich auch immer noch in meinen Ohren höre. Manchmal hat er gesagt, es ist nicht so wichtig, dass ihr richtig spielt, Hauptsache ihr spielt laut. Vor allem bei Gitarren, die irgendwann einfach in Grenze erreicht, dem relativ schnell eine Grenze erreicht, wo es dann nicht mehr lauter geht. Und vor allem, weißt du, wenn du so einem abgebrühten Profimusiker sagst, okay, aber dann sitzen da halt drei Zwölfjährige einfach mit aufgerissenen Augen und hauen einfach in die Seiten, was das Zeug hält, kurz vorm Reissen hauen da rein, völlig ignorierend, was man in welchen Noten spielen soll, ballert da einfach rum und die Leute auf dem Festigen sich auch so, was ist denn eigentlich hier los? Das war auch immer schön. Das ist schön, weil wenn dann die Eltern, die so einen Elternteil plötzlich ruft, ja, spitt mal lauter, spitt mal lauter, man hört euch gar nicht und man hat einfach irgendwann die Grenze erreicht, das ist immer ganz geil. Aber schön war natürlich, ich war ja immer in der Gruppe und da haben wir dann auch schon mal Stücke zusammengespielt und sich gegenseitig begleitet und da war es dann noch immer so, dass teilweise man einfach den Anschluss verloren hat. Wir haben ein Stück, man spielt da zu dritt, gleichzeitig Synchron und einen haut es halt raus und er schafft es nicht mehr, reinzukommen und dann haut es den anderen auch noch raus, weil er merkt der andere es raus und dann spielt nur noch einer alleine weiter, guckt die anderen verdürzt an und die beiden anderen sitzen einfach nur noch da und warten und langsam bricht dieses Stück Stück für Stück zusammen. Oder der Letzte guckt dann die anderen so an, habe ich jetzt gewonnen, habe ich jetzt Musik gewonnen? Oder hört dann auch ganz beschämt irgendwann auf so, okay, dann lassen wir es halt. Okay, komm, wir lassen es, ja. Das ist sehr gut, das ist Gold, das ist Comedy Gold dieser Abende an, aber man war immer sehr aufgeregt. Ja, man war extrem aufgeregtgt, aber man hat sich echt gedacht, warum komme ich überhaupt dazu, was soll das, mir ist es völlig egal, was die Eltern von mir denken, ich will das gar nicht. Danach war ich immer sehr glücklich, ich war davor immer sehr unmotiviert, aber danach dachte ich mir, komm jetzt hast du es geschafft, dann war ich immer sehr motiviert nach diesen Abenden wieder. Naja, das war toll. Wo wir gerade bei Musik sind, man sagt ja immer, früher war alles besser, früher war Musik noch was wert und so. Ist das so? Ja, stimmt. Da ist was dran. Ja, da ist es wahr. Ich glaube nämlich auch. Das ist nämlich aber auch der einzige Teil, wo man den Leuten zustimmen kann, die sagen, früher war alles besser. Weil Musik damals halt noch wesentlich mehr, grösser war, als Musik noch richtig gross war von Olli Schulz. Da hat er recht, muss man sagen. Ist aber ein neues Lied, ne? Ist ein neues Lied? Okay, das widerspricht die ganze ein bisschen. Das relativiert das alles wieder, ja. Nee, aber es ist wirklich so. Gefühlt haben die damals noch eine Message gehabt, und heutzutage geht es nur noch um den schnellen Erfolg. Und man kann Lieder auch nicht mehr so oft anhören, gefühlt. Also diese typischen Lokalradios, die kennst du ja auch, ne? Das geheimnisvolle Geräusch, Achtung! Diese Lokalradios halt, ne? Ich bin ja auch immer so eine gewisse Playlist und gefühlt sind da 80% ältere Lieder. Das hat doch bestimmt auch einen Grund. Ja, weil die Hörer alt sind. Ja, genau. Das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass heute die Musiklandschaft weiter breiter gefächert ist, dass es nicht mehr so diesen krassen Mainstream gibt, wie alle früher Beatles gehört haben und alle früher Beatles geil fanden, sondern dass es heute halt wahnsinnig viele Facetten gibt und deswegen man in der Musik primär entfremdet ist, weil es wahnsinnig viel Musik gibt, mit der du nichts anfangen kannst.
Wohin ging früher gab es halt die Charts und die fanden alle einigermaßen gut und alle konnten sich kommunizieren darüber und heute gibt es halt 80 verschiedene Musikrichtungen mit 80 verschiedenen Charts, das heißt 95 Prozent der Musik, die produziert wird, mit denen kannst du gar nichts anfangen und das ist auch in Ordnung. Früher gab es, ganz, ganz früher gab es sogar nur eine Musikrichtung, weil es halt nur Orchester gab zum Beispiel, also wenn man Konzert, wenn man zum Konzert gegangen ist, hat man nur ein Konzert gesehen. Ja, da gab es schon so ein paar Leute, so Beatniks, die dann irgendwie so in Bars so ein bisschen rumgechillt haben und so. Das glaube ich schon. Ich glaube nicht, dass es früher alles nur Orchester war. Okay. Also von daher. War das Quatsch, was ich erzählt habe. Ich glaube, es ist kommender Quatsch, ja. Es war früher aber auch so, dass die Lieder halt, also wenn man früher zum Konzert gegangen ist und zum Orchester gegangen ist, hat man halt so eine Symphonie gehört, die einfach mal 50 Minuten lang war. Und heutzutage sind Lieder drei Minuten lang. Das ist auch schon ein Trend, dass Lieder immer kürzer werden. Vor allem, man hat sein Lieblingslied vielleicht zwei, drei Male in seinem Leben gehört. Genau. Und heute kann man es sich ununterbrochen anhören. Hörst du, wenn du ein Lieblingslied hast, hast du es immer in Dauerschleife? Genau, so meins. Also ich immer ein Lied bis es zu Tode hasse. Und dann kommt mit Dauerschleife, bis ich es zu Tode hasse.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so.
Tatsächlich so. Aber ist das gut?
Was ich mir tatsächlich auch angewöhnt habe,
in der letzten Zeit habe ich relativ viele Soundtracks gehört,
wo ja oft die Musikstimmungen so
durchmischt sind, so ein bisschen.
Weil was es auf jedem Soundtrack gibt, egal
welcher Film, also auch wenn
der Film, sag ich mal, eine relativ klare
Stimmung hat, irgendwie, wegen Requiem for a Dream Dream irgendwie so ganz depressiv und traurig und down, dann gibt es immer ein Lied, das irgendwo in so einer Partyszene im Hintergrund läuft und was dann auch immer auf der CD ist, was dann überhaupt nicht in das ganze Konzept reinpasst. Gibt's aber immer, jedes Mal. Ja, das ist noch ein Pultivbeispiel, ja.
Naja, aber auf jedem Soundtrack gibt's immer ein Lied, wo man sich denkt, mein Gott, das muss jetzt nicht rein sein. Nur irgendein Lied, das der Protagonist mal im Auto gehört hat, im Autoradio, irgendein Popsong. Und der ist dann auch in einem Soundtrack drin, obwohl er mit der eigentlichen Stimmung des Films überhaupt gar nichts zu tun hat. Ja, das stimmt. Und auch eigentlich gar nicht so ausgewählt wurde, sondern halt nur für, oh, was könnte denn im Radio für einen Trashpop laufen. Aber gut. Aber im Soundtrack muss natürlich alles draus sein. Ich betrüge mich in der Hinsicht selber, also ich höre kein Lied zu Tode, weil ich mir immer sage, das ist bescheuert, das ist eine Kackidee, ich höre es lieber dosiert, dann gefällt es dir in zehn Jahren auch noch, weil es ein gutes Lied ist, stattdessen mache ich mir dann so Playlists, wo halt ganz viele Lieder drin sind, wo auch alte Lieblingslieder drin sind und so, und dann mache ich immer auf den Shuffle-Modus an und dann drücke ich immer so lange nach vorne, drücke ich immer so lange die Lieder weiter, bis es kommt. Und dann ist die lange vorbei und dann mache ich es wieder. Und das ist quasi genau das Gleiche. Aber man denkt halt, man hört es nur ein paar Mal. Selbstbetrug. Selbstbetrug. Sag mal, hast du das nicht auch, wenn du von deiner Grossmutter ein Haus geerbt bekommst und dann ziehst du in das Haus und dann fängt deine Grossmutter in dem Haus an zu spuken? Ich meine, hallo, was ist denn das für ein scheiss Dickmove? Oder erst vererbt man jemanden im Haus und dann fängt man in dem gleichen Haus an zu spuken. Und dann ist meistens noch das Ding, dass da mit der Spannungsbogen gehalten wird, man umzieht und sie dann mitkommt. Ich glaube, das dürfen Geister tatsächlich nicht. Ich glaube, deswegen ist auch der große Schwachpunkt von jedem Geisterhausfilm, dass die Leute einfach nicht ausziehen dürfen. Das ist ganz wichtig, sonst ist der Film einfach vorbei. Sie gehen einfach. Sie spielen alle in einer Welt, in der man nicht umziehen kann. Es ist physikalisch nicht möglich, umzuziehen. Sie kommen auch nicht auf die Idee, oh, da läuft Blut von den Wänden, ach, mal gucken, ob wir nicht irgendwie einen Inquisitor oder so holen, anstatt einfach zu sagen, tschau, mach's gut, wir gehen dann bis später. Das ist wirklich eine interessante Frage. Wie gucken zum Beispiel Profis Horrorfilme? Gucken die Horrorfilme? Was meinst du mit Profis jetzt, welche Profis? Zum Beispiel ein Regisseur, ein super guter Regisseur, guckt sich einen Horrorfilm an. Also wie findet er ihn gut, wenn er gruselig ist? Was zeichnet er einen guten Horrorfilm auf, dass er gruselig ist oder dass er eine gute, geile Story hat? Du willst jetzt auf auf die problematik anspielen dass wenn man sich so lange mit etwas beschäftigt dass man es dann nicht mehr genießen kann ja irgendwann sind die Horrorfilmstilmittel auch mega vorbei einfach ja natürlich aber da gibt es halt wieder neue Trends so wie eine Gitarre sondern wie eine Gitarre kann irgendwann nicht lauter sein ein Horrorfilm kann irgendwann nicht gruseliger sein naja gut ja das stimmt ich habe tatsächlich nicht viel Erfahrung mit Horrorfilmen ich kein großer Horrorfilm-Fan, deswegen kann ich da nicht wahnsinnig viel jetzt sein. Ich bin totalen Fan. Das sind die lustigsten Filme der Welt. Warum reden wir immer über Horrorfilme? Wir reden in jeder zweiten Folge über Horrorfilme, das finde ich nicht gut. Wieso denn das? Das ist keine gute Botschaft an unsere Zuschauer, das gefällt mir einfach nicht. Nochmal zum Thema früher, was es heute, ja, was es ja heute zum Beispiel gibt, ist Elektrizität. So, das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die gab's noch nie. Und ich dachte mir zum Beispiel, ich war mal auf einem ...
Nein, nein, die gab's schon, die gab's irgendwann, gab's sie nicht und dann gab's sie irgendwann. Das war ganz plötzlich, dann gab's von einem auf den anderen Tag, gab's Elektrizität und Autos und so.
Und zwar, ich war mal auf einem LARP, einem Live-Action-Rollplay.
So ein Typ bist du, ne?
Ja, aber unverkleidig.
Nur ein einziges Mal, nur ein einziges Mal. Also das ist so eine Art Rollenspiel, man trifft sich, man verkleidet sich als Ork so ein Elfen und hüpft dann auf irgendeinem Feld durch die Gegend, während irgendwelche Kleinfamilien mit den Kinderwagen vorbeifahren und sich denken, man hat ihren Schaden.
Ich als objektiver Typ kann das erklären. Es sind ein Haufen Freaks, die in echt viele Rollen schlüpfen.
Ein Haufen hässlicher, fetter Jungfrauen, die sich im Umhang anziehen. Die aus ihrem Privatleben flüchten wollen, weil es verkorkst ist, weil sie nie mit Leuten reden. Und dann bilden sich so eine Maske, bilden sich eine Figur, die sich ausdenken, die so ein Übermensch ist. Ich bin der Elf von, der Sohn von Draenor in dritter Generation und ich bin der Prinz von Elbenwald und ich habe schon 50 Dahlia getötet. So in dem, dann stricken sie sich eine Geschichte rum, die total geil ist und vielleicht auch mega kreativ und vielleicht ist doch nicht so unruhig und diese Leute treffen sich dann zusammen und schlüpfen halt ein Wochenende in diese Rolle und dann fahren sie irgendwann nach Hause mit ihrem VW Polo und leben ihr IT-Leben weiter. Ja genau so ist es ist es. Und da war ich mal. Und es sind immer so, da gibt es dann so zwei Spielergruppen. Es gibt dann so zwei Spielergruppen. Es gibt die Spielleitung und die Spieler. Und die Spielleitung, die weiß, was an dem Wochenende passieren wird. Also da gibt es dann auch so einen Plot, eine Geschichte, die erzählt wird. Und die Spieler wissen eben noch nicht, was passiert und müssen dann diesen Plot eben lösen. Und dann greifen irgendwie böse Monster an und dann müssen die Spieler kämpfen und die Spielleiter wissen eben schon, wann die eingreifen. Gibt es die Monster? Spielen die andere Leute? Die gibt es ja nicht wirklich. Es gibt keine Monster, Florian. Ja, doch, aber die ziehen sich dann halt Verkleidungen von Monstern an. Und es gab dann auch einen schönen Moment, wo am Morgen des zweiten Tages haben dann eben die Bösen angegriffen. Aber ich lag noch im Zelt und hab geschlafen und alle so, oh, Angriff zu den Waffen und ich so, oh nee, hab ich nochmal umgedreht. Und es war auch so, wo die Immersion in die Fantasywelt nicht hundertprozentig klappte, einfach so, ach nee, komm, da hast du keinen Bock drauf zu kämpfen. Aber das war auch ganz schön. Aber was mir da aufgefallen ist, und zwar hatte ich da so einen Mantel dabei, so einen Fellmantel, unter dem ich auch geschlafen habe. Und wenn man da in der Nacht so ganz schnell mit der Hand drübergerieben hat, dann ist ein Gin entstanden tatsächlich, der konnte dir dann Wünsche be... Und nee, tatsächlich, wenn man mit der Hand über dieses Fell gerubbelt hat, dann ist Elektrizität entstanden und so kleine Funken sind dann gesprungen, so kleine Stromschläge gab es dann.
Also wenn es stockdumel war, konnte man die... Wenn man mit der Hand über dieses Fell gerubbelt hat, dann ist Elektrizität entstanden und so kleine Funken sind dann gesprungen, so kleine Stromschläge gab es dann.
Also wenn es stockdumelig war, konnte man die tatsächlich gut sehen.
Du warst Electric Man. Du hast nicht ganz ins Szenario gepasst.
Ich hatte das falsche Kostüm an, ja. Wie Electro Man.
Wir sind Orks, wir machen Füße mit Pfeil und Bogen und ich bin Electric Man.
Es gibt auch bei jedem Mittelalter-Larb einen Typen, der zum Spaß ein Stormtrooper-Kostüm anhat und einfach im Hintergrund rumläuft und man sich denkt, oh du Depp einfach, halt die Fresse. Der auf jedem Foto auch noch drauf ist und es kein vernünftiges Foto gibt. Genau, überall ist noch Harry Potter drauf und Edward aus Twilight. Nein, nein, dann dachte ich mir, ich meine, dieser Mantel war ein Gegenstand, den es im Mittelalter auch schon gab. Und wie hat man sich diesen Effekt im Mittelalter erklärt, dass wenn man in der Nacht über so ein Feld rüber rubbelt, dass dann lauter Blitze und Lichtblitze geschlagen ist? Wie zur Hölle haben die sich das erklärt? Die hatten ja noch nicht mal ansatzweise ein Konzept von Elektrizität. Die haben zwar Blitze gesehen, aber die Tatsache, dass man Blitze durch Reiben auf Fell irgendwo selber erzeugen kann, what? Also ich meine, wie haben die das denn wahrgenommen? Haben die das einfach ignoriert und dachten sich, okay, habe ich mir eingebildet oder was auch immer? Oder hat er nicht mal eben gefragt, Entschuldigung, können wir mal ganz kurz Kreuzzüge und Exemprenzbrennung ganz kurz immer sein lassen und uns mal ganz kurz darum kümmern, was das für eine abgefahrene Scheiße ist, die da gerade abgeht. Die 95 Thesen, die irgendwer in die Kirche gehangen hat, sind bestimmt sehr interessant. Einfach mal kurz abnehmen, ja. Aber da sind Funken eben entstanden. Ja, genau. Warum? Aber das ist ja dieses geile Szenario, dass man sich vorstellt, wie sind Dinge entstanden? Wer war der erste Mensch, der? Das passt ja auch ganz gut jetzt mal. In dieser Folge passt es wenigstens mal. Was war früher, was war heute? Der erste Mensch, der, habe ich mal irgendwann gesagt, auf Stelzen gelaufen ist.
Alle mussten gesagt haben, das ist brilliant, das ist fucking brilliant.
Andere Leute, wer war der erste Mensch, der nach einem Auftritt eines künstlerischen Aktes angefangen hat zu klatschen?
Ja.
Wie bekloppt muss der, wie ist das entstanden? Hat er zufällig, hat er sich irgendwie in die Hände geklatscht?
Und wie viele Aufführungen hat es gedauert, bis andere Leutefällig, er hat sich irgendwie in die Hände geklatscht?
Und wie viele Aufführungen hat es gedauert, bis andere Leute mitgeklatscht haben? Wie oft hat der alleine geklatscht?
Oder sind Dinge auch manchmal von einem auf den anderen Tag entstanden? Plötzlich haben wir es alle gemacht einfach, weil es im Gehirn plötzlich so einen Funken gab. Oder zum Beispiel, also zum Beispiel jetzt, als Beispiel, zum Beispiel William Shakespeare hat ja wahnsinnig viele neue Worte entwickelt, also ich glaube über zweieinhalbtausend und so Redewendungen und so. Und da gab es ja auch den Moment, wo das erste Mal ein Schauspieler auf der Bühne stand und ein Stück von Shakespeare gespielt hat. Wie haben die Leute darauf reagiert? Also ich mache jetzt mal irgendein Beispiel, zum Beispiel wenn man sagt, I'm in a pickle, ja, Pickle heißt ja Gewürzgürkchen, ja, wenn man sagt, I'm in a pickle, ich bin in einer unangenehmen, gefahrvollen Situation, wie hat das Publikum das erste Mal darauf reagiert? Also das sind so Fragen, die würde ich gerne mal stellen öffentlich in so einem Podcast oder sowas. Also würde ich das mal gerne öffentlich machen, die Diskussion da aufmachen. Oder wer war der erste Mensch, der Popcorn gemacht hat? Das haben wir auch schon mal besprochen. Ja, vor allem, was er sich gedacht hat. Das ist wirklich eine geile Vorstellung, wie jemand plötzlich Mais warm macht. Einfach, weiss ich nicht, ich mache mir Mais warm, weil ich Langeweile habe gerade und dann plötzlich platzen diese Dinger. Was muss er gedacht haben?
Ich glaube, früher im Mittelalter und so, als das Feuer noch die Hauptunterhaltungsquelle war, also wie bei den Simpsons im Mittelalter, wo dann alle nicht um den Fernseher rumsitzen, sondern um die Feuerstelle, da war ja die Feuer, Feuer war ja der heiße Scheiss. Also das war ja richtig die Unterhaltungszentrale. Und ich glaube, da hat man schon einfach mal gesagt, so was haben wir da, wir halten jetzt einfach mal alles ins Feuer. Wir gucken einfach mal, was passiert. Stein ins Feuer, Kind ins Feuer, irgendwie Eidechse ins Feuer, einfach mal gucken, was passiert. Diese rothaarige Nachbarin ins Feuer. Genau, einfach mal gucken, ja. Aber im Mittelalter war vieles schlecht, muss man mal offen zugeben, im Mittelalter war vieles schlecht, aber die hatten diese grandiose Idee, also die Herrscher zum Beispiel, die hatten ja immer Gaukler. Gaukler, die mussten immer gut drauf sein, die mussten unterhalten und wenn die einen scheiß Gag gemacht haben, hat man die einfach umgebracht. Da war keine Frage, du hast mich aufgeregt, du hast einen scheiß Gag gemacht, du bist tot. Das war einfach eine gute Herangehensweise. Das war eine gute Motivation einfach, da hängst du dich dann rein. Was gibt es doch für erste Menschen, die irgendwas gemacht haben? Umarmung ist für mich auch immer so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, die erste Umarmung der Menschheit muss echt awkward gewesen sein. Sau awkward gewesen sein. So, äh, sorry, kann ich dir helfen? Was ist los? Was genau ist dein Problem gerade? Ja. Oder der erste Handschlag. Ja. Der erste Schwertkampf. Gut, der hält jetzt so ein Ding auf mich, was genau muss ich jetzt machen und was genau würde das Ding machen, wenn es mich trifft, hat man ja vorher noch nicht gesehen.
Aber ich finde auch so diese Sprichwörter, also wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, wie das erste Mal so ein Sprichwort, als zum Beispiel die Katze im Sack kaufen. Ich weiss nicht, ob du weißt, woher das kommt, aber früher gab es ja nicht so Metzgergeschäfte,
früher gab es ja noch kein Internet und kein WLAN.
Da mussten die Leute noch wirklich in die Metzgerei gehen und sich da Fleisch kaufen.
Aber sogar noch davor gab es reisende Händler.
Wir landen immer bei Horrorfilmen und Sprichwörtern.
Das ist so unser Ding, das ist so unterbewusst unser Ding. Wir lieben das anscheinend.
Es gab dann reisende Händler, die sind dann von Stadt zu Stadt gefahren und haben dann Fleisch verkauft in Säcken. Und haben dann so einen Sack Fleisch für fünf Euro verkauft oder was auch immer. Und die haben dann so gesagt, ja, ich hätte gerne einen Sack Huhn. Und dann haben die so den Sack aufgemacht, ah, hier ist der Huhn drin, zack, verkauft. Aber man wusste ja nicht, was unter dem Huhn in dem Sack alles drin war. Da könnte ja auch ganz anderes Fleisch drin gewesen sein, minderwertiges Fleisch, wie zum Beispiel Hundefleisch, ja, und dann haben die Leute gesagt, oh mein Gott, ich habe heute den Hund im Sack gekauft, und daraus ist dann langsam entstanden, einem Geschenkengaul schaut man nicht ins Maul. Was genau das Gegenteil bedeutet. Was genau das Gegenteil bedeutet. Also auch hier haben wir wieder, das finde ich das tolle an Sprichwörtern, Sprichwörter widersprechen sich ja immer.
Das ist so geil.
Die lösen sich ja letztendlich auf.
Ja genau, das haben wir wieder, das finde ich ja solle an Sprichwörtern, Sprichwörter widersprechen sich ja immer. Das ist so geil. Die lösen sich ja letztendlich auf.
Ja genau, das haben wir auch mal gesagt. Irgendwann ist ein Null am Ende. Wir haben schon alles gesagt.
Bei Folge 15, glaube ich, sind wir jetzt tatsächlich am Ende. Wir haben nichts mehr zu sagen.
Wir haben alles gesagt, wir haben alle Pranks gemacht. Ich würde jetzt zum Beispiel gerne, apropos Zeit, in die Zukunft
reisen und gucken, was wir so in Folge 55 machen. Oh ja, das wäre super geil.
Worüber reden wir denn da? Ist das unsere Horrorfilmfolge? Gibt es uns dann noch? Ja, wahrscheinlich, genau. Sprichwörter Teil vier, das ist das vierte Mal, zu sprechen, über Sprichwörter. Aber wahrscheinlich haben wir dann lauter so ganz verrückte Rubriken eingebaut. Weißt du, woher das Sprichwort kommt, jemandem einen Korb geben? Ach komm, jetzt, ja, weiss ich, aber wir machen jetzt keine, von mir aus das eine Sprichwort noch, aber mehr dann auch nicht. Komm, erzähl's. Nee, ich weiss es nicht. Mach mir jetzt auch schon wahnsinnig. Nee, ich weiss es nicht, ich wollte einfach nur fragen. Wirklich, ist das dein Ernst? Nee, das war irgendwann gehört, aber das wollte ich des Gags wegen jetzt sagen so. Also früher in der Ritterszeit, wenn man die Burgdame bezirzen wollte, dann musste man ja irgendwie über die Burgmauer und dann war es üblich, dass sich der, genau, der Flöte spielende Hofmann, der Ritter, hat sich dann in einen Korb gesetzt und wurde dann die Burgmauer hochgezogen und da konnte dann die Lady, die Dame der Burg, konnte dann sehen, womit sie es zu tun hatte. Und wenn der Lady eben der Umschmeichelnde nicht gefallen hat, dann wurde dieser Korb einfach wieder runtergefallen lassen und dann hat man sozusagen einen Korb bekommen. Das hat sich dann langsam über ganz Britannien und Germanien in weiterentwickelt, diese Redensart, und irgendwann kam es dann auch bei uns an, denn da gab es nämlich noch kein Internet, da war es noch nicht so, dass man sich über WLAN überall einhecken konnte und einklinken konnte, nein, da musste man sowas wirklich noch weitreichend tatsächlich verbreiten. Sehr gut. Ja, ich habe folgende Idee gehabt auch. Also, Kunst. Im weitesten Sinne ist das, was wir machen, Kunst. Würdest du mir da recht geben? Ja. Es ist ja so, dass Kunst immer etwas Neues kreieren ist. Etwas kreierendes Kreativität, das steckt ja auch schon drin. Aber irgendwann gibt es ja alles es ja alles Dinge schon, irgendwann wurden alle Dinge schon mal gemacht, es gibt eine begrenzte Anzahl von Dingen, die man auf der Erde machen kann, begrenzt durch irgendwelche Möglichkeiten, die man auf der Erde hat, das sind unendlich viele, also hat man auch wahrscheinlich unendlich viele Möglichkeiten, aber früher hat man halt mehr und die naheliegenden Dinge wurden noch nicht gemacht, es wurden Dinge erfunden und dann zum Beispiel, wäre ich gerne in einer Ehrenzeit geboren, wo man zum Beispiel, der erste Mensch, der auf irgendwas geklopft hat und so, der hat natürlich was entwickelt und was erfunden und das war cool und dann haben die gefeiert. Aber stellst du dir nicht auch manchmal vor, dass wenn jetzt irgendwie du zum Beispiel einen Künstler komplett aus der Geschichte streichen könntest und du dann selbst seine Lieder schreibst, weil du kennst die Lieder schon, aber du reist einfach vor Michael Jackson und schreibst die Lieder alle selber aus dem Gedächtnis. Ich wir schon aufgefragt. Und das wäre super gut. Da hätte ich echt Bock drauf. Das wäre super geil. Da würde ich denken, was das für ein cooler ... Oh! Ihn exakt kopieren einfach. Oder ein Arbeitskollege von uns, der behauptet nämlich die ganze Zeit, er hätte Ebay erfunden. Also er hätte die Idee gehabt von Ebay. Aber angenommen, man reist vor die Zeit, also man denkt, gedanklich ist man jetzt in der Zeit, wo es Ebay noch nicht gab. Da haben auch schon viele Leute, glaube ich, so geredet wie wir jetzt und haben gesagt, ja, es gibt schon viele Dinge, man kann nicht mehr viele Dinge erfinden, aber jede Zeit und jede Möglichkeit bringt ja auch wieder neue Möglichkeiten mit sich. Wahrscheinlich haben da auch viele diesen Gedanken gehabt, man könnte jetzt ein Online-Auktionshaus erfinden, aber ich glaube, es ist halt mehr noch, diese Mot Motivation, das auch umzusetzen. Ja. Ich glaube sowieso, dass zum Beispiel die Was? Ich glaube sowieso, dass die Römer im alten Rom zum Beispiel den ganzen Tag rumsassen und denken, Alter, wie geil wäre es, wenn es schon Internet gäbe. Alter, noch zweitausend Jahre. Wie kriegen wir diese Zeit denn nur rum? Was machen wir denn heute noch?
Gladiatorenkämpfe.
Wenn es Tinder gäbe, wenn es Twitter gäbe, wenn es Tumblr gäbe, Alter, wie geil das wäre, aber naja, gibt es halt noch nicht, blöd. Aber so stelle ich mir das Altertum vor eigentlich, das ist ein ganzes, so ein Schmachten in die Zukunft, so ein, oh man, ich will ein Tandem, ich will Eldies, sowas. Sag mal … Ich … ja?
Nee, ich wollte kurz sagen, also ich wollte dich fragen, ob du vielleicht Ideen hast
heutzutage, vielleicht sowas wie Ebay, sowas, sowas eine App, irgendwie was, was die Zeit revolutionieren würde.
Ja, aber da werde ich jetzt sicher nicht drüber reden, weil ich genau weiß, dass wir Geier-Zuhörer haben, die uns jede Idee klauen, wie zum Beispiel mein Schal mit Taschen, ja, habe ich entwickelt, Schal mit Taschen, wurde geklaut.
So, zack, geklaut, Millionenumsatz, Riesengeschäft, meine Idee, Capes mit Taschen, gleiche Geschichte, wurde auch geklaut, war ursprünglich meine Idee, aber kannst ja nichts machen. Was ist mit Leiseball geworden, ja, wer hat sich die Rechte an dem Ding gesichert, was ist mit Grenzball geworden, die ganzen Ideen, die ich dummerweise im Podcast. Ich habe versucht, zu vertuschen, Leiseball geklaut zu haben, indem ich mich Steffen Tietgen genannt habe und es im Patentamt eingereicht habe. Aber du bist mir doch auf die Schlüche gekommen, muss man dazu sagen. Es hat dann tatsächlich doch funktioniert, ja. Nee, ich wollte kurz mal eine App-Ideen. Ich habe vier App-Ideen, genau, habe ich mir eben ausgedacht, als ich mich hier auch vorbereitet habe. Okay, cool. Möchtest du die hören? Cool, dass du sowas auch mit mir kommunizierst, damit ich mich auch vorbereiten kann. Nee, hör mal aus Scheiss eben, ich hätte kurz Zeit, du hast mich sitzen lassen, ich war um 17 Uhr schon da, du bist um 17.30 Uhr gekommen, ja, da hast du das. Ich hab's nicht nummeriert, aber ich fang mal oben an. Tinder mit Quests. Ich würde es Tinder Quest nennen, weil ich ein kreativer Typ bin, und die Hauptaufgabe besteht darin, dass man auch Frauen nach rechts und links swipen kann, aber du musst halt, zum Beispiel, das ist sau sexistisch, du musst fünf Brünette haben, um zum Beispiel etwas freizuschalten, du musst fünf Blonde haben, um dann so einen Punkt zu bekommen, dann kriegst du halt, dann darfst du einen Filter auf dein Bild machen. Ich dachte, du musst dann erst bei den Dates gewisse Aufgaben erfüllen. Das ist der nächste Schritt. Das ist der nächste Schritt. Irgendwas gibt es so eine Liga und du sammest immer Punkte und am Ende gibt es so eine Liga wie bei Chris Duell und es ist sausexistisch. Es ist wirklich sehr sexistisch, ja. Aber es ist, glaube ich, eine gute Idee. Ich glaube, es würde funktionieren. Es muss ja nicht immer einem selber gefallen, was man da erfindet. Ich glaube, Werner von Braun hat auch nicht die Atombombe erfüllen wollen. Dann eine App, wo man hören kann, was der Nebenmann hört an Musik. Also ich zum Beispiel bin gespannt, ich sehe neben mir in der Bahn ein Mädchen, sie wippt mit dem Kopf, anscheinend hört sich das beste Lied der Welt, ihrem Gesicht nach zu urteilen. Und dann würde ich gerne hören, was sie hört. Du drückst auf die App, die muss es vielleicht bestätigen, vielleicht auch nicht, weil es eine illegale App ist, und dann hört man direkt, was sie hört. Fände ich super interessant. Aber ist es dann auch so ein Dating-Tool, also kann man dadurch einen Kontakt herstellen, dann zusammenwippen und zusammen anfangen zu singen? Gut, dass du mir eine Frage stellst und die selber beantworten kannst. Natürlich! Natürlich, das ist der Premium-Vorteil. Du kannst direkt ein Gespräch anfangen. Oh, ich sehe, du bist auch ein Fan von XYZ, Queen. Wie findest du die Idee? Ich finde die nicht schlecht eigentlich. Ja, finde ich gut. Du kannst dich auch, vielleicht ist es schon irgendwie besser, du kannst dich auch so ganz nah an sie ranlehnen, dass du über ihre Kopfhörer hörst, was sie hört. Dann hast du direkt Nähe hergestellt und kannst direkt drauf ein... Das ist die analoge Version davon. Das ist die analoge Version, ja, die mittelalterliche Version. Naja, so würde es ich machen. Flohmärkte sind ja auch nichts anderes als analoges Ebay. Ja. Ja, dann das ein Textverarbeitungsprogramm, wo man nichts löschen kann und für jeden Löschmove, also jedes Mal, wo man die Delete-Taste drücken würde, müsste man Geld zahlen, genau. Das war die Idee, sagen wir mal ein Euro pro Delete. Also das heißt, man müsste sich von vornherein, wie bei alten Schreibmaschinen, da kommt man auch eine Zeit lang noch löschen drücken, aber theoretisch gäbe es diese Taste nicht und du musst halt immer überlegen erst, was du schreibst. Also wie damals, wenn du Briefe geschrieben hast, da hat man sich ja erst Gedanken gemacht, hat es dann geschrieben und hat dann nicht diesen, damit man keinen Briefverschleiss hatte. Der hätte man beim Computer, gut, hätte man den nicht, gar nicht erst, aber wie lustig das wäre und ich würde einen Haufen Geld verdienen, wenn Leute halt für einen Euro die Gewielkaste kaufen, aktivieren. Ich finde, das ist so ziemlich die dümmste Idee, die ich je gehört habe. Okay. Die letzte Idee, die ich habe, ist, lesen, was der andere schreibt. Habe ich es formuliert? Es gibt da diese geile ... Eine Kombination aus den anderen Apps einfach. Ja, genau. Man kann beim anderen für Geld deinen Text löschen. Genau. Man sieht ja unten schon, Florentin Will schreibt zum Beispiel. Wenn wir gerade chatten und uns sagen, was wir gerade anhaben und so, dann steht ja unten immer, Florentin Will schreibt. Wie geil wäre es, wenn man sehen könnte, was du schreibst und was du dann wieder löscht. Und der andere wüsste es nicht. Das wäre ganz schön toll. Das wäre der absolute Horror, glaube ich. Vor allem das ist ja genau der Sinn der Sache, dass man es nicht mitkriegt.
Ja. Aber gut, ja, warum sollte man es machen? Was hat man davon? Ach, dass man beim anderen dann... Das ist nicht so eine Debatte. Das ist erst der nächste Schritt. Erst ist das Brainstorming, wo man sich Ideen austauscht und dann kommt der Kritikschritt. Wusstest du, dass Walt Disney, der Mann, der wohl die besten Geschichten der Welt erfunden hat, dass der eine spezielle Herangehensweise hatte, um sich Geschichten auszudenken, um kreativ zu sein? Ja, wusste ich, aber fahr fort. Du weißt immer schon alles. Du hast es schon acht Mal erzählt. Echt jetzt? Ich habe schon vielen Leuten das erzählt, das stimmt. Er hatte zunächst die Traumphase, wo er sich Dinge ausgedacht hat, wo er sich, er hatte auch drei Zimmer dafür, er war erst in seinem Traumzimmer, hat er sich Dinge ausgedacht und hat so seine Fantasie spielen lassen, Dinge erschaffen, sprechende Tiere, sprechende Tiere, wie geil wäre es, wie war der erste Mensch, der Popcorn erfunden hat. Und im zweiten Schritt hat er das dann auf die Wirklichkeit, auf die Realisierbarkeit überprüft. Und im dritten Schritt … Was relativ einfach ist, wenn man Zeichenregel Filme macht, da gibt es relativ wenige Limitationen, deswegen war der Raum auch sehr klein. Der Raum war sehr klein. So ein Flur, der war sehr hässlich, sehr dunkel, keine Lampe, gar nichts. Und dann im dritten Zimmer, das war dann das Kritikerzimmer, da hat er sich Gedanken gemacht, was ist wirklich gut. Das ist ein großer Fehler. Viele sind erst gedanklich in diesem Kritikerraum und schmeißen direkt Ideen weg, die sie haben, anstatt erst mal durch eine Idee auf die nächste zu kommen und dann halt den nächsten Schritt auszusortieren.
Ja, das ist eine echt bahnbrechende Erkenntnis tatsächlich. Du hast die Kreativität revolutioniert, glaube ich. Das ist nicht schlecht. Sich erst mal Sachen ohne Druck zu überlegen und dann zu sortieren, das ist schon nicht schlecht. Fällt mir gut. Aber du hast vorhin gesagt, von wegen, man könnte nichts Neues erschaffen, weil alles schon gemacht wurde. Nein, das habe ich nur so gesagt. Ich finde, du übersiehst eine Sache, denn du hast etwas, das niemand anderes hat und das auch in der Geschichte noch niemals jemand hatte. Die Liebe. Du hast dich. Du hast dich, Stefan Titzel. Niemand auf der ganzen Welt jemals hatte Stefan Titzel. Ich glaube, ich muss mich übergeben. Und das ist das, was dich einzigartig macht. Das einzige Problem, womit du in die Gefahr gerätst, dass du Dinge machst, die schon gemacht wurden, ist, wenn du versuchst, andere zu kopieren, wenn du neidisch bist, wenn du versuchst, den Erfolg von anderen zu kopieren, wenn du auf dein Inneres, auf dein Herz hörst, wenn du nur das, was dein Herz sagt, was aus dir rausspricht, nur wenn du das aufnimmst in deine Kunst, dann hast du die Chance, etwas wirklich einzigartiges zu machen. Wenn du nicht mal die Chance hast, fehlzuschlagen, zu scheitern, dann kannst du per Definition gar nichts Neues machen. Das sagt der, von dem ich am meisten weiss, dass er Tweets einfach eins zu eins aus dem Englischen übersetzt und dem Deutschen wieder raushaut. Von dem muss ich mir so einen drei Minuten Vortrag über Einzigartigkeit anhören. Das ist schon lustig. Ja, ich bin nun mal nicht einzigartig, aber du bist einzigartig.
Du bist Stefan Tietze, du hast wirklich die Flamme in dir.
Du kannst wirklich Dinge neu schaffen.
Danke. Wärst du lieber in einer anderen Zeit geboren? Wärst du zum Beispiel lieber
1930 geboren, 1933 geboren?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein? Das nicht. Naja, doch, manchmal schon.
Also 1933 geboren ist natürlich
schon ein bisschen lame, glaube ich.
Also als Kind, glaube ich, es nicht so cool. Aber so ...
Wie kommst du ... Ja, aber ...
Aber so ... Also wenn man ... Na ja, also ... Na ja ...
Oh, ein Eichhörnchen!
Manchmal stelle ich mir das schon vor, wie es wäre, so aber na ja.
Biene Meier heute. Biene Meier habe ich gesehen, ist jetzt 3D animiert. schon vor, wie es wäre so, aber naja, man ist ja, wird man ja nicht.
Biene Meier heute, Biene Meier habe ich gesehen,
ist jetzt 3D animiert.
Das ist zum Beispiel was, was sehr uncool ist.
Aber jetzt ist es nicht auch wieder dieser, nein, ich möchte das auch mal
so in so einen anti-retro, anti-nostalgischen
Bewegung hier schaffen, immer dieses
man darf die Klassiker nicht verändern,
mein Gott, verdammt nochmal,
was ist denn los mit euch, seid ihr wirklich schon so eingestaubt und eingesessen, dass man nicht mal ein bisschen was Neues ausprobieren kann? Das ist doch genau das Problem, dass du, du sagst genau, was du gerade gesagt hast, du bist schon wieder im Kritikermodus, nicht einfach mal sagen, hey, Biene-Meyer, warum nicht einfach mal 3D, hier nicht einfach mal Pixar-Style, sondern gleich sagen, nein, man darf mit Biene-Meyer nichts Neues machen, natürlich, man darf mit allem was Neues machen, man kann einfach neue Sachen mischen, sich neue Sachen überlegen und einfach mal gucken, was passiert. Immer dieses Festhalten an dieser Romantik und diese Dinge müssen so und so und man muss das immer, dieser Wein muss so und so getrunken werden und zudem ist es immer das und nein, man darf auf gar keinen Fall das Bier so und so einstecken und immer dieses festgefahrene, ritualisierte, starre Denken, chillt doch einfach mal euer scheiss Leben. Es ist doch meine Entscheidung, ob ich eine Hose in der U-Bahn anhabe. Es ist doch meine Entscheidung, was ich zu essen bestelle und wie viel. Es ist doch meine Entscheidung, ob ich diese Frau anfasse oder nicht. Ja, es ist doch meine Entscheidung, wie viel ich euch zahle für euer Essen. Es ist doch meine Entscheidung, was ich wann zu wem sage. Da müsst ihr euch doch nicht immer einmischen, dieses, oh, das sagt man aber nicht hier und da, das geht mir auf die Nerven, dieses immer, kommt doch mal raus aus eurem Kopf, raus aus eurem Horizont, guckt doch mal auf oben euch, was ist hinter euch, was ist eigentlich ein Schatten, was sind das für Konzepte? Und nicht immer aus diesem Denken so, na hier. Ja, aber ich finde es relativ witzig eigentlich, weil es war ja schon diese 2D-Animation, wie das damals gezeichnet war, es war ja schon sehr gut, es war ja schon sehr weit fortgeschritten und es war ja schon auch sehr gut entwickelt und es hat sich bewährt und plötzlich macht man es nicht mehr, sondern macht es stattdessen etwas, was man weniger gut kann und auch allen anderen Nebenprodukten, Konkurrenzprodukten, wie ... Naruto.
Ja, zum Beispiel, einfach den hinterherhinkt und macht dann einfach 3D daraus und sieht einfach scheiße aus.
Ich meine, das wissen die auch selber wahrscheinlich. Aber warum machen die das? Ja gut, weil es halt weniger Geld kostet. Mein Gott, wir müssen das so tun, als hätten wir keine Ahnung von der Welt.
Mein Gott, manche Dinge werden halt anders gemacht, weil es weniger kostet.
So, und dann gibt es eine Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung, die Leute überlegen sich, okay, es kostet 30 Prozent. Du glaubst, eine Dimension mehr kostet weniger? Ja, Idiot. Das glaubst du auch nicht wirklich. Ja gut, es kostet mehr natürlich, aber dann machen die eine Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung und schreiben, ja hier, so viel kostet das mehr, wir erwarten, dass es so wenig... Die haben eben eine Dimension, die haben eine fucking Dimension da hinzugeführt. Und dann erstmal die vierte Dimension, da wird es dann richtig... Was ist eigentlich die vierte Dimension nochmal? Zeit! Wow, wir sind am Ende. Wenn der Podcast jetzt vorbei wäre, wäre das so geil, aber leider müssen wir nur eine Viertelstunde reden. Scheiße, scheiße, wo ist die Zeitreise, wenn wir überbrauchen. Aber ganz ehrlich, warum hängen wir da in diesem Rahmen fest? Letztes Mal haben wir eine Dreiviertelstunde-Sendung gemacht und es kam gut an. Also, es kam genau so an. Es kam überhaupt nicht an, wir haben überhaupt kein Feedback bekommen. Wie immer, eigentlich ist es genau immer dasselbe. Ja, ja, nee, ist kein Problem. Ich meine, es ist halt so, ne? Also ich meine, du sagst ja oft, irgendwie Dinge zu verstehen ist eigentlich nicht so gut. Weil je mehr Dinge man versteht, desto klarer werden die Dinge und desto weniger Freiraum hat man eigentlich für sich selbst. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit Filmen beschäftigt und mit so dem dramaturgischen Aufbau von Sachen und genau so dem Geschichtenerzählen, so diesem ganz klassischen aristotelischen Dreiakt-Sinfonie. Und dann ist es natürlich, wenn man so einen Film anschaut, natürlich immer schwer, weil dann schaut man zum Beispiel mit jemandem einen Film an und dann sagt er, oh mein Gott, warum hat er das denn jetzt gemacht? Und dann sagst du, naja, es ist relativ wichtig, dass vor dem Einbruch des zweiten Akts nochmal die Problematik des Helden dargestellt wird und es muss den als Gädenpol geben, so, was ist das für eine Antwort? Ohne die Ritalation würde halt kein Klimax entstehen. Ja, genau. Und es ist natürlich immer klar, also das eigentliche Statement des Films muss innerhalb der ersten zehn Minuten schon genannt werden, es muss ein gewisses Foreshadowing geben. Und deswegen ist das jetzt passiert. Und na ja, natürlich bist du vielleicht nicht der grösste Fan von Skylar White, aber denk mal nach. Skylar White brauchst du eben als moralische Instanz. Sie muss die Bitch sein. Damit Walter White als gespaltene Figur überhaupt funktioniert, gäbe es keine Skylar White, könnte man die Figur Walter White überhaupt nicht erzählen. Das heißt, indem du sagst, ich mag Walter White, magst du auch gleich Skylar White. aber dann sagen Leute, Skyler White ist so eine Bitch, die Serie wäre viel besser gewesen, wenn sie nicht drin gewesen wäre. Nee, eben überhaupt nicht, weil Skyler White a der ganze Antrieb der Serie überhaupt ist und b überhaupt den ganzen inneren Konflikt von Walter White manifestiert, indem sie die moralische Instanz ist. Das ist es! Das habe ich mir auch immer gedacht, aber man traut sich auch nicht zu sagen, man heißt wieder äh, Beffer, Beffer. Nein, das ist... Ich hasse den Charakter, ey, ich hasse es, weil der ist immer so scheisse zum Hauptgerät. Ja, aber die Schauspielerin ist ganz geil und so, und eigentlich ist es auch ganz geil, weil sie muss ja irgendwie auch gut spielen, sonst würde man sie ja nicht scheisse finden. Nein, das ist nicht der Grund, warum die sie scheisse finden, sondern weil du die Story nicht verstanden hast. Und weil es im Echten gibt, es leben auch Leute, die scheiße sind. Und es ist ja auch mega, aber die ist ja nicht scheiße. Es ist ja auch mega interessant zu sehen, dass man plötzlich mit jemandem sympathisiert, der offensichtlich den grössten Scheiss der Welt macht, Leute umbringt und den trotzdem am besten findet. Und da ist halt diese weinerliche Heulsuse, die im Endeffekt aber nur zu allen versucht, nett zu sein und ihr scheiss Drecksleben in den Griff zu bekommen. Und die man plötzlich scheiße. Warum, ist das so? Das hinterfragt dich doch auch selber. Ja, aber natürlich soll man so ja auch Filme sehen, man soll ja Skylar White hassen, man soll sie ja scheiße finden, aber es ist natürlich irgendwo ein oberflächlicher Hass, weil man natürlich schon, wenn man sich überlegt, wie funktioniert überhaupt die Serie, wie funktionieren überhaupt Geschichten, natürlich man schon schnell an den Punkt kommt, wo man sagt, ja, das muss halt passieren. Das ist halt einfach nicht random, sondern es gibt halt gewisse Strukturen, die in so einer Serie, in so einer Narrative einfach passieren müssen. Da muss es eben Antagonisten geben und jemand, der eben das Über-Ich verkörpert. Aber da ist Game of Thrones, da ist Game of Thrones, es ist wirklich, wir sind nur drei bei drei Themen und jetzt sind wir bei Serien, unserem letzten großen Thema, was wir beide gemeinsam haben, wieder angekommen. Aber es ist so, das haben die auch bei Game of Thrones, haben die das den Voraus, die killen einfach solche Charaktere von der ein oder anderen Folge, killen die die einfach und dann erscheint ein neuer Antagonist in der nächsten Folge, bis man merkt, ja gut, der kommt nicht so gut an. Und dann killt man den wieder und dann kommt wieder ein neuer und man hat halt die Vielfalt. Ich finde, bei Game of Thrones ist es jetzt fast schon ein bisschen zu krass mit dem ganzen Töten. Ich glaube, in der nächsten Staffel ist es so, oh, eine neue Figur wird eingetönt, okay, gut, TikTok, wann geht sie drauf, muss ich mir den Namen überhaupt noch merken, so. Man versucht sich gar nicht mehr, irgendwen zu sympathisch zu finden. Ja genau, man ist effektiv innerlich erschüttert, man will überhaupt keine emotionale Bindung mehr aufbauen, weil man Angst hat, sie wieder zu verlieren, was aber auch eine sehr, sag ich mal, eine sehr menschliche Botschaft ist. Was war dein Moment, wo du angefangen hast, die Game of Thrones so zu gucken, dass du dich mit gar keinem mehr sympathisierst? Ja, da will ich jetzt nicht spoilern, das ist Quatsch. Ich will jetzt nicht spoilern, aber ich bin ja großer Fan von dem Typen, den niemand mag, sag ich mal, der in einer herrschenden Position. Joffrey. Es ist egal. Wir wollen nicht spoilern, spoilern sind nicht cool. Reden wir lieber mal lieber mehr über Pranks. Wir sind ja beide, wir sind ja die Prankbrothers, ne, also wenn wir ins Studio kommen, dann zittert die Sekretärin schon. Uiuiui, was haben sie sich jetzt schon wieder ausgedacht, oh mein Gott, irgendwie, was haben sie gemacht, haben sie wieder Zucker ins Leitungswasser getan. Und zack, schon wieder den Stuhl weggezogen, und ha ha, da liegt sie, und das Büro abklaut. Und schon wieder den Computer ausgeschaltet, und ich hab schon mit meiner Maus meiner Bluetooth-Maus, fahre ich auf deinem Bildschirm rum und dann habe ich dir schon wieder die Bildschirmhelligkeit runtergezogen und du denkst, der Bildschirm wäre aus, was ist das für ein Teil? Die Prankbrothers, ey, ich finde das immer so geil, ich komme ins Studio. Wir kommen rein und sagen, der eine von den Prankbrothers ist wieder da. Ah, Prankbrothers One, Prankbrothers Junior. Und weisst du, wir kommen ja ins Studio und du sitzt da schon immer mit deinem Hundeblick und wartest und hast irgendwie deine vier Boxen Sushi gegessen oder was auch immer. Die ganze Tonkabine stinkt nach Fisch und dann kommst du immer rein und ah, Prank, Prank, ich hab dir keines mehr übrig gelassen und ich, ah klar, geiler Prank, yo, high five. Das finde ich einfach so geil, dass wir da auf so eine gewisse Ebene gekommen sind. Und wir haben ja schon einiges durchgemacht. Erinnerst du mich noch damals, der Praktikant? Ja, der war so, der war aber auch scheiße. Also der hat uns auch genervt und dann haben wir uns überlegt, komm, wir stellen jetzt einen richtig krassen Streich, spielen wir dem jetzt. Und dann haben wir uns zusammengesetzt und haben uns überlegt, was kann man machen. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, wir haben die halbe Nacht, glaube ich, durch. Ja, hatten wir aber lange tatsächlich auf dem Teller auch. Der war lange im Rennen noch, auch sehr lange im Rennen, war die elektronische Türgriff, der elektronische Türknopf war auch sehr lange im Rennen, haben wir aber alles hat abdagelegt und am Ende war es was. Es war dann doch tatsächlich Hausfriedensbruch, haben wir uns dann tatsächlich dazu entschieden und das war der Hammer. Ja, ist ein bisschen nach hinten losgegangen, hinten raus. Wir haben sehr täuschend echt aussehende Waffen benutzt, um uns Zugriff zu verschaffen. Dann kam die Polizei, gut, dann wurde es sehr schnell eskaliert. Aber die fand es auch ein bisschen lustig. Dann ist es sehr schnell eskaliert. Mir wurde einmal ins Bein geschossen, aber jetzt lachen wir noch darüber. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe mal eine Bank überfallen, hier so Pistole, Hände hoch, Geld her, dann kam die Polizei und ich so, just kidding, just kidding. Und alle haben gelacht, alle haben alle footloose getanzt. Genau, und deswegen sind wir ja raus. Also nur mal so, also falls ihr vorhabt, eine Straftat zu begehen, sobald die Polizei kommt, just kidding, Spaß. Hast du mal aus Versehen, hast du mal aus Versehen irgendwie einen Diebstahl begangen oder ein Kundelein? Ja, ich habe tatsächlich mal Schinken geklaut. Aus Versehen? Sehr bewusst. Ich habe aus Versehen Schinken geklaut, weil ich war Einkaufen und habe Sachen in meinem Rucksack getan und dann an der Kasse habe ich alles aufs Parkett gelegt, also auf dem Boden habe ich alles gelegt und dann, das ist immer für die Kassierer immer blöd, ich muss dann alles vom Boden aufheben und dann, als ich dann wieder alles eingeräumt hatte, habe ich gemerkt, oh, den Schinken habe ich gar nicht bezahlt, der war hinter meinem Mathebuch und dann dachte ich mir, ui, was soll ich jetzt machen, soll ich ihn jetzt,, ich habe ihn dann gegessen letztendlich und ja, das war dann die ganze Story. Ich habe mal wirklich, ich habe auch Diebstahl begangen, also es gab damals immer, als ich noch kleiner war, da gab es in unserer Stadt immer so eine Mini-Ausführung der Stadt, also die Stadt, wo ich herkommen war, es kamen und es gab immer Mini-Kamen, da konnte man so eine Freizeit, zwei Wochen Freizeit-Fun und ...
Da konnte man auf den Häusern rumklettern, war alles noch mal ein Kleiner.
Nein, nein, es war alles, es war halt in so einem Jugendzentrum wurde dann quasi eine Stadt aufgebaut. Es gab auch ein Postbot, es gab eine Bank, es gab eine Bar und dann waren halt ganz viele Leute und jeder hat jeden Tag andere Berufe, man musste mal zum Arbeitsamt gehen und dann konnte man Berufe ausüben den ganzen Tag. Man konnte zum Beispiel backen, man konnte im Einwohnermeldeamt sein, man konnte Unterhaltung machen, man konnte Theater spielen, man konnte zur Tanzgruppe gehen, du konntest im Filmstudio arbeiten, du konntest halt wirklich alle Berufe ausüben, quasi die es gibt, halt im Kleinen und einem wurde alles erklärt und so. Das war eigentlich ganz geil. Und ich habe mich halt, relativ früh habe ich verstanden, dass man zur Bank muss, weil die Bank hat immer gewonnen. War schon sehr früh, bin ich ins Casino gegangen und ich habe das relativ früh gecheckt. Und da habe ich mir, da gab es auch eine Währung. Im zweiten Semester BWL, oder? Es gab auch eine Währung, Minimo hieß die damals.
So kleine Scheine, die wurden dann gedruckt, damit konntest du auch bezahlen.
Also das war die Währung da.
Du konntest damit, du konntest abgeben und dann hast du ein Brötchen bekommen.
Oder du konntest zwei, dann hast du einen Donut bekommen oder was auch immer. Ja, ich habe das Konzept von Währung, glaube ich, schon ganz gut. Und dann habe ich ab dem zweiten Tag immer in der Bank gearbeitet und habe immer, wenn keiner guckt, halt alles, alles, was da an Geld war, habe ich mir eingesteckt. Das war immer ganz geil. Und dann haben wir alle ... Dieses Ferienspiel habe ich quasi im Alleingang gewonnen.
Durchgecheatet. Völlig durchgecheatet. Es war so, es war richtig, richtig nice. Und dann konnte ich am Ende, haben sich alle gefragt, woher kommt denn das Geld her und warum haben wir alle nichts, warum war es so viel. Und die haben wirklich hart gearbeitet und haben halt in der Bäckerei geschuftet, bis sie dann mal so fünf Minimo pro Tag verdienen konnten. Und ich habe einfach so zehntausend gehabt plötzlich. Und alle, was, ich weiß nicht, der König der Stadt plötzlich für einen Tag halt. Niemand konnte es sich erklären. Nein, das war echt total geil. Also das ist wirklich cool, vor allem weil diese simplifizierten Systeme, die ein grosses Vorbild haben, ja immer irgendwelche Schwachstellen haben. Da war es einfach, dass man sehr leicht, sehr viel Geld bestehlen konnte. Aber du hast wahrscheinlich eine wertvolle Lektion fürs Leben gelernt. Dass man immer klauen sollte, weil dann hast du gewonnen. Ja, absolut. Aber ich meine, wie selbstbewusst ist es eigentlich von der Stadt, zu sagen, als Attraktion für unsere Kinder machen wir noch mal eine kleine Stadt. Oder so als grosse Attraktion in der Stadt ist noch mal so ein Modell, so ein 1 zu 100 Modell von der Stadt in der Mitte der Stadt. So, oh, was kann man denn hier sehen? Ja, Sie können in unserer Stadt noch mal unsere Stadt sehen, in klein. So ein sehr großes Selbstbewusstsein der Stadt. Und hier haben Sie einen sehr kleinen, sehr kleinen Fotoapparat, mit dem Sie Filter machen können, die fast wie original aussehen. Genau, ja. Und gucken Sie mal, was ist denn da in der Modellstadt in der Mitte? Nochmal unsere Stadt in 1 zu 1000. Das ist ja verrückt. Und sind Sie das? Das sind Sie, wie Sie vor der kleinen Stadt in der kleinen Stadt stehen. Ist das egal? Genau. Und ansonsten können Sie noch einen Heissluftballon mieten, dann können Sie ganz hoch in die Luft fahren und sich unsere Stadt anschauen. Heissluftballons. Einfach die ganze Stadt. Echt toll. Wer war eigentlich der war eigentlich der erste Mensch, der einen Heissluftballon am Himmel gesehen hat? Statt zu fragen, wer war der erste Mensch, der mit einem Heissluftballon geflogen ist? Wer war der erste Mensch, der auf dem Boden stand und einen Heissluftballon oben in der Luft gesehen hat? Was muss der gedacht haben? Ja, gute Frage. Was ist das denn? Aber tatsächlich, ich habe letztens mal einen Artikel gelesen über den ältesten Witz der Welt. Ja. Und also ich glaube nicht, dass es wirklich der älteste Witz der Welt war, aber ich glaube so der älteste Witz auf Twitter oder so. Oder was ist der am häufigsten, alter, fick mal deine Scheißflöte ohne Witz. Oder so im Sinne so, was ist der am häufigsten wieder getweetete Witz oder irgendwie sowas. Und da ist es ja, es gibt ja im... Das ist aber erst ein ganz schöner Sprung gewesen für den ersten Witz, der jemals gemacht wurde. So exeben im... Was war ein okayer Twitter-Gag? Im Zeitraum vom 8. bis zum 16. Mai oft getweetete Gag. Und es gibt ja bei Superman, im ersten Superman-Film, gibt es ja diese berühmte Szene It's a bird! No, it's a plane! plane, no, it's Superman, ja, und da hat jemand völlig zu Recht die Frage gestellt, warum waren die ersten beiden Personen eigentlich so aufgeregt, it's a bird, wer schreit das denn einfach so mit einem Vogel sieht, it's a bird, und der zweite auch, no, it's a plane, I mean, who are you, who the fuck are you, are you talking to me? Das ist echt grossartig. Aber das ist echt, da hat man nie dran gedacht eigentlich, das stimmt schon tatsächlich. It's a bird! Ja, und was ich sage, das müssen die grössten Ornithologen der Welt gewesen sein, so die grössten Vogelfans der Welt. It's a bird! Ja, das ist genau dein Problem. Es wäre einfach gut, wenn es da nicht weitergegangen wäre. Wahrscheinlich tausendmal davor ist es so passiert, bevor dann die anderen beiden Teile kamen. Aber genau so ist es passiert. It's a bird! Ja, vor allem geil. Geil, dass die grössten Vogelfans, die grössten Planespotter und Superman in einem Ort da sind. Da haben schon sehr viel zusammengekommen. Der grösste Zufall. Gab es schon Zufälle? Ich glaube, nein. Nein. Aber ich glaube, sowas könnte heute nicht mehr passieren, weil die Leute viel zu unkommunikativ sind. Die Leute haben ja heute gar keine Lust mehr, mit anderen Leuten auf der Strasse zu reden. Wenn jemand irgendwie mitten in der Fußgängerzone schreit, it's a bird, würde ja niemand überhaupt darauf reagieren. Sowas könnte gar nicht mehr zustande kommen. Nee, ich habe es gegoogelt, das kann kein Vogel sein, Vogel fliegen, Vögel fliegen nicht so hoch. Das wäre auch eine langweilige Konversation. Ja, genau so. Ja, lass mich kurz meine Vogel-App rausholen. Nee, ist Superman. Nee, ist nur Superman, ist nur Superman, das steht hier. Und der lateinische Name von Superman ist... Übermensch. Ja, genau. Ich habe mein Referat über Superman gehalten, wollte ich nur mal sagen. Möchtest du die nächste Folge aufheben? Ja, aber habe ich dir schon mal von meinem Genghis Khan-Referat erzählt? Nee, aber du hast auch noch nie erzählt, wie Shakespeare Wörter erfunden hat. Soll ich das von meinem Genghis Khan-Referat erzählen oder nicht? Oder habe ich das wirklich schon ein paar Mal? Nein. Und zwar habe ich das mit meinem Bruder vorbereitet, also mein Bruder ist vorbeigelaufen, als ich alleine in meinem Zimmer das gemacht habe, und dann hat er gesagt, hör mal zu, Referate, es ist völlig egal, was du sagst, solange das Ende gut ist. Die Leute erinnern sich nur ans Ende. Und wenn das Ende richtig der Knall ist, dann kriegst du eine gute Noten. Du hast scheissegelabert, hast am Ende angefangen, Dschingis Khan zu singen. Wenn das Ende, Dsching, Dschingis Khan, nee, und er hat gesagt, mach doch mal folgenden Gag. Am Ende sagst du, ja, hier Dschingis Khan, hier ganze Mongolei erobert und so ein Kram. Aber der letzte Satz könnte sein. Und heutzutage lebt tatsächlich noch ein Nachfahre von Genghis Khan. Erkennt ihn vielleicht? Oliver Khan. Aber ich dachte mir, das ist die beste Idee ever. Das ist der beste Gag der Welt. Das war der erste und der beste Gag der Welt. Ja gut, ich habe mir sofort aufgeschrieben und dachte dachte mir, okay, geil, habe sofort aufgehört zu recherchieren, weil ich mir dachte, es stimmt, es ist tatsächlich so, der Rest ist vollkommen egal. Wenn der Ende ein Lacher ist, gehen die Leute einfach mit einem guten Gefühl raus. Und dann tatsächlich, ich in der Schule, stehe da völlig verunsichert, ja, und der hat dann auch so Kriegsstrategien entworfen, wo er dann irgendwie so ganz viele Strohpuppen aufgestellt hat, damit er zeigen wollte, dass seine Armee grösser ist. Und dann haben die anderen mit noch mehr angegriffen und dann, also ich weiß auch nicht genau, was der Sinn dahinter war, aber es hat auf jeden Fall funktioniert. Und na ja, Genghis Khan dachte, er sei unsterblich, ist gestorben, als er vom Pferd gefallen ist und ja, vielleicht kennt ihr noch einen anderen Nachfahren von Genghis Khan. Oliver Khan. Ja, vielen Dank. Ja, Florentin, drei Glatt. Das waren jetzt vier Minuten, mehr hast du nicht. Nee, aber es ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr schlecht angekommen. Echt? Ja, extrem schlecht angekommen, weil man natürlich auch, was man nicht bedacht hatte, nachdem man 15 Minuten lang Scheiße erzählt hat, hört einem auch keiner mehr zu. Das heißt, man kriegt auch überhaupt nicht mit, dass das Referat jetzt zu Ende ist. Aber es hat mal einmal, da wollte ich auch noch einen kurzen Shoutout, ein kurzer Shoutout an Max tatsächlich, einen der coolsten Typen der Welt. Und er hat mal ein Buchreferat gehalten über das Parfum oder das Parfüm, je nachdem, ja, sehr bekanntes Buch. Und er hatte, und da ist, glaube ich, jeder Deutschlehrerin das Wasser im Mund zusammengelaufen, jeder Deutsche Referendarin ist da feucht geworden. Und zwar hat er, während er das Buch aus dem Buch vorgelesen hat und Referat gehalten hat, hat er eine Rosenblüte durch die Reihen gehen lassen. Und dann konnte jeder mal an dieser Rosenblüte riechen, weil es in dem Buch ja viel um Gerüche geht und so. Und da hat er wirklich mit dem Move direkt die Eins bekommen. Zack, das war, wo alle dachten so, wow, nicht schlecht. Mir ist aufgefallen, es ist scheißegal, was du sagst. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das Ende wichtig ist, sondern was du rumgibst. Bei ihm war es die Rose. Ich habe mal ein Referat über die Stimme gehalten und wie wir halt Buchstaben bilden. Becher Spucke rumgibt. Wo wird das B? Ich habe einen Becher, ich kann mal Eigenurin rumgibt. Also B zum Beispiel bildest du ja vorne, N hinten. Und da gab es eine geile Übung, habe ich gefunden, in der man die ganze Zeit mit einem Korken spricht. Dann habe ich so einen Korken herumge Korken herumgegeben, ganz viele Korken war das, weiß ich gar nicht mehr, und habe aber nicht bedacht, dass alle dabei reden müssen. Das war ein sehr, sehr lautes Referat. Keiner hat mich mehr verstanden, weil alle durcheinander geredet haben, der Lehrer war außer sich, weil alle plötzlich angefangen haben zu reden und er hat die Bande nicht mehr in den Griff bekommen. Und es war so, es ging völlig nach hinten los, es ging völlig nach hinten los. Aber es gab am Ende eine ganz gute Note, weil es war halt eine lustige Idee. Alle haben mit diesem Korken im Mund gesprochen. Was aber eine total gute Idee ist, weil anstatt selber ein Referat zu halten, bringst du deine Zuschauer dazu zu reden. Ja, leider habe ich aber nicht so weit gedacht und habe wirklich ein Referat vorbereitet und war eigentlich auch ein bisschen traurig, dass mir bloß die Kerl einmal zuhört. So, wir haben jetzt... Naja, zum Thema Zeit nochmal. Ja, Zeit ist ein schlechtes Thema. Zeit ist kein gutes Thema, tatsächlich. Aber vierte Dimension ist ja Zeit, ne? Hast du das jemals verstanden, so mit diesem Dimensionenmodell? Ja, das ist ja auch alles, also dass die vierte Dimension Zeit ist, ist ja relativ gut, bei der Relativitätstheorie zu erklären.
Die Relativitätstheorie ist ja auch ein Begriff, ne?
Ja.
Da gibt es ja den Begriff der Zeitdilatation, und zwar, dass Zeit relativ ist. Je nachdem, wie schnell man sich bewegt, geht die Zeit langsamer. Total interessant, man kann also Zeitreisen sind auf jeden Fall möglich, halt in die Zukunft auf jeden Fall schon mal. Wenn man mit einem sehr schnellen Raumschiff unterwegs wäre, was annähernd Lichtgeschwindigkeit reist, kann man, wenn man, sagen wir mal, sieben Jahre unterwegs ist, 500 Jahre in die Zukunft reisen, theoretisch. Man würde sieben Jahre altern, die Erde würde 500 Jahre altern. Das ist ganz interessant. Auf jeden Fall ein Gedanke wert. Ich bedanke mich bei Florentin Will, wir haben eine Stunde zwei geredet, wir werden diese Folge nicht schneiden, weil es eine herausragende Folge war, naja, aber wir haben halt ganz gut am Stück geredet und deswegen bedanke ich mich bei meinem Co-Moderator Florentin Will. Vielen Dank, danke schön. Für weitere Gags einfach auf Twitter, add das Podcast UFO und ansonsten folgt uns auf Facebook, auf Twitter und lasst meine iTunes-Rezension da, die muss auch nicht immer gut sein, je nachdem. Stefan Titzel.
Dankeschön, ich freue mich, dass ich da war.
Oh, hörst du die Musik schon?
Wir heben ab.
Nee, da höre ich nicht.
Ist es ein Vogel?
Nein!
Es ist die Podcast-Endmusik, die wir geklaut haben.